welcome back to las vegas now from
funnel cakes to corn dogs and ice cream
you can get a little bit of everything
this weekend at the great american
foodie fest the sponsors of this next
segment jillian is live in henderson
with a preview of all the things going
on hey girl
hey rocky yeah i don't know how i would
ever pick which food truck to choose
from but good thing the festival is
three days long so you can try it all
i'm joined by oliver again and okay i
didn't win a prize at the carnival game
but it was a lot of fun let's talk about
some of the entertainment elements that
are going on over here
so look we have a huge carnival as you
can tell with all kinds of rides games
which is great for the families so bring
out the kids and have a good time and we
saw the stage getting situated earlier
what kind of music can people expect out
there oh we've got all genres of music
so from live bands to djs we have it all
so you can get some food get some drink
ride some rides have fun this is great
for families and real quick again let's
give us the hours so everyone knows
where and when they can come hang out so
friday we open at five from five to
eleven saturday is twelve to eleven and
sunday is uh twelve to ten so like we
said plenty of time to eat have fun come
hang out and in the shade it's really
nice over here and rocky since we were
talking with you earlier i gotta show
you i found the hoop shots game i feel
like if you were out here you would
totally win the prize i didn't want to
put my skills to the test because it's
kind of embarrassing but rocky girl if
you were here i know i know you can make
it in so lots of fun going out here
food trucks rides um there is a ferris
wheel you said you're afraid of heights
so maybe you'll avoid that but i had to
call you out
oliver thank you so much this is such a
fun experience and for now i'll send it
back to you guys
jillian thank you so much yeah she's
right about that that's where i would
have been at the entire i would have
eaten a full meal and been at the hoop
shots for sure you and i both now ted is
the is the wind going to you know throw
my
nothing
you'll hit it no matter what okay